the opening ceremonies in Pyongyang are
less than a week away but not all the
hazards at this year's games will be on
the slopes or on the ice the Department
of Homeland Security issued a warning
about cyber crimes potentially at the
hands of North Korea's vast and very
capable hacking operation one that can
target athletes and spectators alike and
some attacks may have already begun
wired has been covering these concerns
and this morning we are joined by its
editor-in-chief Nicholas Thompson Nick
good morning morning Alex
okay so wired calls these games a nexus
of hacker skullduggery sounds like Andy
Greenberg read dark dark stuff what's
happening over there so what we know so
far is there two major hacks so the
Russians were mostly banned from the
Olympics and they're not happy about
that so they're hacking into individual
athletes they're hacking into
organizations they're trying to show
that Russia is not the only country that
doped so we've got fancy bear on the
Russian side doing that then secondly we
have another large hacking organization
we're not exactly sure who it is
possibly North Korea but we can't be
certain hacking into basically every
Olympic organization including the ski
resorts the tourism boards we don't know
what the intention is but lots of
hackers have already compromised lots of
computers Wow these are already the most
hacked games ever is this correct I
think it's fair to say that's a little
hard to define but I think we can call
it that and this is not uncommon though
right I mean Olympic Games before have
been hacked yeah so Olympics are you
know their sporting events but they're
also a political event and as we know
hacking is now part of sort of every
major political event there is this time
it's gonna be particularly part of it
because Russia got banned Russia is not
happy when it's got banned and there are
a lot of hackers in Russia so they've
really set themselves up for this to be
complicated I mean as you mentioned
several winter sports federations have
already been targeted I mean do we know
the scope of this and and but but we
don't know the intention is what you're
saying right we don't know the intention
surely part of the intention is to
expose doping and to kind of make things
confusing there could be much darker
intentions right it could be that people
are trying to hack in and get the
information lots of thing
people go to the Olympics lots of rich
people go to the fix you could be
wanting to hack into them possibly you
could want to mess with the games right
one of the nightmare scenarios would be
somebody figures out a way to I don't
know screw up the figure skating judging
right and then you have an international
disaster and of course you could also
have the worst case scenario is the
power goes out or something like that no
well what about we you say Olympics are
a political event relations between
North Korea and South Korea have been
warming if North Korea is indeed one of
these hacking parties what are the
implications as far as that date on tif
that's what you can call it yes so I
don't think South Korea will be
particularly happy if it turns out that
North Korea has hacked and it does
really disrupt it so the warming has
been going on for not that long a time
the hacking has been going on for much
longer it may be the case that North
Korea started a hacking operation before
the slight that talks it may be the case
that North Korea is doing this anyway
just to have a little bit of leverage
and it may also be the case that it's
somebody else not North Korea doing this
if you're attending these games do you
need to worry about this yes you do you
need to be careful and you need to have
good computer hygiene you need to use
two-factor authentication on all of your
accounts you need to make sure that you
don't open any suspicious-looking
attachment at all you need to not use
open Wi-Fi you need to turn off Wi-Fi
and Bluetooth when you don't need them
you need to be careful you may even want
to get kind of an old computer that
doesn't have any of your personal for
your browsing the old clamshell Mac and
the like orange color bring the
clamshell Mac when you go over there and
delete all your files before you get
there and revisit your emails from the
late 90s I would delete just too before
you head over there Nick Thompson
raising the red flag red flag of warning
always good to see you thanks for your
time thank you